while it takes care of that what
happened to the Hat raymond buck gave
the president it's probably somewhere in
the kennedy library I would I would
guess come up to the mic if here will
bow and tell us I'm not sure if it
counties that might be in the State
Archives I know that the suit that he
was wearing that day is in the archives
the reason I know that is that I asked
him later if he still had to copy the
story that I had hanging about our
Chronicle poll he said yes he said when
when when Kennedy asked me about he said
I had it in my coat pocket I didn't show
it then I said he's just telling your
coat pocket he said I don't know the
suits in the State Archives we call it a
call the State Archives and asked him
about that they said that's who was sent
twice to Washington for examination and
that that that store would not be there
we're now checking with the economy the
archives at the LBJ library they have
about 50 boxes if people are interested
in that sort of thing they have about 50
boxes of the economy papers and they
said we haven't catalogued all those yet
so we don't know we might find her story
there okay thank you very much beau I'm
just going to quickly run through a
couple of these questions and then we're
going to talk about some of the more
bizarre things and the coverage of this
story what happened to the minister who
reported D is d students in his church
were cheering about the assassination
actually he was talking about University
Park school over here in the Highland
Park system someone told me recently I
think he now has a church we're in
Washington Washington DC that's right
and here's another one at least two
reporters have mentioned seeing Tippit's
casket or possibly tip its body at
Parkland I'm stood tippet was DOA at
Methodist could someone clarify this who
would like to take that on
come up here chariot to the mic you you
qualified to get this is Jerry Hill who
had a career with Channel five and then
with The Times Herald and and Channel
four that's right and also with the
Dallas PD and the Jerry had an awful lot
to do with an awful lot of things so as
straighten without thinkin he was taken
to Methodist Central which is on
Colorado by Dudley humulus but when they
wanted a post-mortem for legal purposes
the medical examiner was at Parkland so
they transferred the body over there for
the post-mortem that's how the body got
too far okay Thank You Jerry
why is there no copy of the full page ad
denouncing JFK on display here frankly
we didn't have one
it's we certainly we're not trying to
just suppress it but our our archival
our archivist is that the term our
archivist just didn't have a copy of it
what happened to Tippit's Widow and the
six hundred thousand dollars that the
American public contributed to her Jerry
you might be in position I guess as much
as anyone else to respond to that and
what was the amount of money that miss
tip it to God Mike you follow that it
was about six hundred thousand what
happened was that she asked some
specific police officers lynn king who
was later chief of police was one of
them v k hip skinned who was another
they counted all the money they were the
ones that made the deposits they
counseled her on getting an investment
counselor trust funds were set up for
her and the kids she later married
another police officer
who
has since died and she is a widow and is
still fairly active I understand in the
police officers Wives organization okay
Thank You Jerry again oh excuse me I
think I can answer why I want it dad's
not up here what about that as a letter
yeah go ahead
in the Dallas news I don't believe
there's much coordinated effort and not
fog darn paint or anybody is up to the
media we were not trying to you know we
were not trying to get displays we
actually want to thank our historian
Farris roots to who supplied us with the
most of these and he is the one that is
responsible for bringing the things that
we have and we do appreciate that very
much affairs couple other questions with
all the hours Oswald spent being
interrogated
why was there apparently no record no
tape written or otherwise of the
responses from the most notorious
criminal suspect of the century okay and
I know several of you want to get on
that Mike
don't try all right Wes come on up here
to the mic and tell us about what you
know that then I've heard a version of
it missing in the oral histories that
Bob Porter and I are doing for the for
the Dallas County Historical Foundation
Henry Wade made the statement there
there was no tape recorder in the police
station nor was there any at the Dallas
County headquarters you got to remember
tape recording was just coming in and
was just getting popular at that time
and to have that kind of equipment at
that time was fairly fairly far advanced
now that was just henry's statement okay
thank you i I'd always heard this story
and and I I know what Tim Timmons was in
the audience earlier today he was the
assistant US DEA at the time and Bob
Gimlin from the FBI was here and I'd
always heard story that captain Fritz
just come to charge that
interrogation and he just didn't want
any help from anybody and he asked the
questions and that's probably about as
close to being right as you can be and
the captain ran his own ship and the it
was a it was not a federal offense in
that correct at the time it was a it was
a state state case and it was handled by
the Dallas Police Department Oh
okay come on up Jim the investigation of
the president's murder was a State
offense he was not covered by federal
statutes at that time now I understand
that the the federal the law the
Congress had written laws protected all
the other government officials but for
some reason the president was omitted
Tim Timmons is that correct okay so it
was a State offense the FBI was simply
assisting the Dallas Police Department
in the investigation no that's all they
could do it would not it did not cover
hurdle jurisdiction okay now here's one
I don't really understand but maybe
together we can figure this out all
right I have really enjoyed hearing
these journalists recalling that weekend
for the most part it sounds as if a good
job was done that being the case how did
the ball get dropped so badly so shortly
thereafter I don't understand the
question so we can't answer something
that I've always wondered about Mike
Cochran you uh you were over at the
cellar where you no no I was with the
Secret Service and a White House staff
and all that crew Thursday night before
the ascent well that's what yeah they
went to with everybody was at the Press
Club and the reason for that was back
then of course there was no place in
town to get a mixed drink we didn't have
liquor by the drink back in the Stone
Age and the so everybody came to the
Press Club and about three o'clock I
think some of this week's Secret Service
agents and some other folks just headed
to the headed to the cellar and I don't
I know that's it I think they had a
Senate inquiry into
the seller and the Secret Service
sometime sometime after that but I know
I didn't I had to be up the next morning
so I didn't get to go this up okay I and
I'm going to ask something personal now
this this is kind of an inside thing and
unless you know Huffaker and wise and
all of this group of mind back from
those days you won't really appreciate
this but you'll bear with me
bob was down in the basement that
morning and he and Nelson Benton's from
the late Nelson Benton that that were
kind of taking turns just sort of
waiting things out until they brought us
wall down and so when they brought him
down and turned out that Bob had the mic
and I was back to the newsroom we were
watching this and so Bob starts
screaming into that mic Lee Harold has
been shot Lee Harold has been shot and
I'm kicking the wastebasket thing his
name ain't Harold and Huffaker has got
us to tell us why he called him Lee
Harold and he's going to hang it on
somebody we all know they're gonna quit
they're gonna put that on my epitaph my
andy warhol 15 minutes and i got almost
to tell this please what happened was
that when when Nelson and Dan Rather and
I was sort of rotating around City Hall
and trading off with the CBS live
television Mike one of us would stand by
the mic and New York would call for us
on just a couple of minutes notice and
we would have to give a summary of how
everything stood at that time and also
we would we would be among those pushy
television reporters who would crowd up
to chief curry and the other officials
who passed through the hallways up there
and Dan spent most of his time elsewhere
in town but Nelson and I would circulate
around
station and try to to verify items of
information and do that sort of thing
and during one of those times on the
Saturday before Oswald was shot on
Sunday I I thought well I had I had gone
by the way my I'd been at Parkland
Hospital the previous evening and my
assignment at the police station didn't
begin until that Saturday morning and so
I had a full set of notes that I had
already received from Warren folks who
had been our reporter there the previous
night and on that set of notes it had
all the correct information it had Lee
Harvey Oswald age 24 ex-marine and all
of those items that I needed to know to
go ahead and and continue the reporting
and I thought well nobody's really gone
in and checked the public information
officer yet so during a time when Nelson
had the mic while I left and went down
to Glenn King's office he was the police
public information officer at the time
and Glenn King wherever you are I'm
gonna blame you for this but I sat down
across the desk from Glenn and I began
to go through my notes and just
double-check every piece of information
I had because I was always very thorough
later became a college professor you can
understand so I went over every item of
information Lee Harvey Oswald I read him
and he said no it's Lee Harold Oswald
and I said well now everybody has been I
mean since yesterday everybody's been
saying Lee Harvey Oswald are you certain
that this is Lee Harold Oswald and he
said absolutely it's Lee Harold Oswell I
said when I Glen where did you get that
information he said I got it off the
arrest record so I thought okay and I
marked it out I still have my notes
where I marked out Lee Harvey and wrote
in Lee Harold and from that moment on I
thought I was the only guy who was right
I have ruined myself for this okay thank
you
here's something for Jack Tinsley a jack
someone wants to know how did you manage
to get in the School Book Depository
building after the drive over from Fort
Worth since it was closed off
immediately after the assassination
making his way now to the mic is mr.
Tinsley who moved a little faster when
he came in well the answer is I don't
know but I got in a hitchhike from
Parkland Parkland Hospital downtown I
got in and the foreman took me up to the
6th floor I don't know what time it was
you know I wasn't keeping track of time
but I did get in it was not closed off
and I was there okay
the I don't know how many of you
remember that this really was the second
visit of JFK to Dallas during his
presidency and the first visit and a lot
of us in this room covered that he came
to say a deathbed goodbye to Sam Rayburn
and I remember remember we all out at
Baylor Hospital and I was out there I've
been out there good bit over the last
month since two of our daughters have
presented us with the new grandchildren
in that time and the other day when I
was out there and thinking about coming
to this meeting today and I remembered
back and sure enough the president was
out there but he was in the now the town
and nothing like this took place he went
to mr. Sam's funeral in Bonham Texas and
pictures in adorn the Press Club Bobby
and can I add a comment contribute them
to what was asked about why the ball was
dropped that is presume
assuming that these conspiracies said I
agree with Mary Elizabeth wood was smart
that's my personal opinion I don't know
okay but keep in mind early in the 60s
print media was dominant in television
and electronic is dominant now but I
want to correct something about Secret
Service men didn't pen me and bill went
through today yeah I remember gets a
little fuzzy about it but a rookie cop
who tried to pull a gun on us but I made
two whiskey runs and that was mentioned
and I didn't find any whiskey for basket
I found okra colas up paragons boo the
boys and Paula cream didn't touch a pint
of whiskey that proved the sent me over
to over Dallas hotel to get him a pint
and I carried the NSAIDs on Dez and he
said thanks Tom
somebody's anti Dallas Barrett Tom we
really would like to I don't want to cut
you short but we do want to kind of keep
this thing moving along here's a
question who were the pallbearers for
Oswald's funeral wolf the pallbearers
present please stand one two three four
I thought we had five Jerry is ill okay
who'd like to tell the story on that
Mike why don't you oh you won't tell it
you want Mike to tell okay I do want to
say one thing about it of course we were
the big issue on that day was whether or
not
Oswald's body was actually in the coffin
and
and the end the police chief finally he
didn't want to be fooled either and he
went in to check it but when it came
time to take in the casket down the
biggest issue was who's going to carry
it down there weren't any family members
whatever and so I finally ended up on
one of the corners and the thing that
scared the living daylights out of me
was two things one that sucker was heavy
I had never listed the casket in my life
I didn't realize they were heavy
particularly with bodies in there and
number two I represented the Dallas
Morning News a very conservative
newspaper and here I was carrying the
assassin down to a great site thank God
somebody said this is making history and
since I also had to shoot photographs I
popped off and a thought that the Bolton
a guy who replaced me on the casket and
I got these belts carrying it down to
the graveside well not I heard I've
heard this story in in lack you and the
Cochran gonna have to get me straight on
this one of you was started out to be a
pallbearer and the other said well if
the AP is there I got to be there too or
if the UPI is there I got to be there
too what's the story they they were
recruiting well number one you
everybody's got to understand that that
Awful's popularity that day was at an
all-time low
there weren't a bunch of people running
up to volunteer and so when they tried
to get somebody to to do it well two
things it became obvious that if we were
going to write a story about the burial
of Lee Harvey Oswald and bury myself so
so then they but they but what they did
was they I don't remember who it was it
asked me to do it and I said no and I
turn around there was Preston Burke FBI
jumping right up there and I said if you
fee is gonna do it I got to do it so
Preston who spent a career kicking my
ass I wasn't gonna let him do it on the
on the coffin what well my name is John
McConnell I work with Star Telegram
still then I worked for him then the I
know how memories changed I knew Groody
Miller the guy that brought the body out
there I was a night police reporter and
gritty walked over to me and he said
John will you help me unload the body
and there was absolutely mike is right
the only people there was the Osmo
family and the preacher and so ingredie
said do you think the newsman will be
Paul bearer's and I said well I'm sure
they will and Cochran was right too and
as a result eyes will have won through
many pallbearers you normally have eight
in he had nine around the casket one
other thing I remember was who was the
ninth one town I do not remember I know
it was one of them a Secret Service
agent I've heard that
I know he had one thing let's see there
all right we have a dispute here that
may never be settled somebody there were
seven or there were nine the other thing
I remember about all this was there was
a reporter there from the paper on our
name and he immediately after the casket
got there started saying that there was
not a body in there there was a sack of
potatoes in there and that were the
conspiracy theory had already started
that they were burying potatoes instead
of Oz well one other quick thing about
my part in it when we got back to the
Star Telegram we had approximately six
people out there and one of our
reporters was a guy who spoke Russian
and he had interviewed marina and so
chief Craig who y'all met this morning
out a huge man who's about six foot five
and I have never seen chief mad but one
time anyway he came over to me my
nickname is Bucky and he said Bucky I
want you to get the notes from the rest
reporters and you write the story
so I started around and all the
reporters agreed except then this other
reporter Dan Bates i'll give his name
and he said since he worked the
afternoon paper he's going to write an
exclusive about his interview of marina
so then was quite a big fella himself
and i learned early on in life that the
bigger they are they're harder they fall
is not necessarily true bigger they are
the harder they knock hello
so i went over and told chief craig that
everybody give me their notes but dan
bates and chief craig went over and he
said dan I want you to give Bucky your
notes and Dan said I'm writing this
exclusively for the evening star
telegram and Chiefs nose started getting
red and he reached down and grabbed Dan
by the shoulder and he said you son of a
[ __ ]
gonna get bucket your nose in the band
said yes sir I'm typing right because he
had asked her such things was she really
from Russia I mean what kind of country
was Russia we have okay here's another
here's another question from that vast
audience out there incidentally have any
more questions to get them up here we'll
try and answer you to see how fully we
answer these questions please fully
explain the dried chicken bones
mentioned earlier I'll take a little bit
of a hand of that and anybody else
wanted to join in do what okay come on
uphill and see if your story varies from
mine all right there were these three
guys in the fifth floor window
James German Bunny Rae Williams and
Harold Norman and they had lunch down
there and are you going to dispute me
nope okay we had two sets of chicken
bones in the School Book Depository when
we went into the building to search it
and we got there before captain Fritz
did so we did police procedure there was
an officer named Roy Westfall there were
two deputy sheriff's one of them name
was Mooney I do not remember the other
ones named myself and a uniformed
officer we went to the top floor which
was the seventh floor we checked the
roof we came back to the seventh floor
we searched it we left the uniformed
officer on the seventh floor so that the
anybody in the building could not double
back on us and get behind us in an area
we had already cleared we went down to
the sixth floor and at that point Mooney
found the barricade
that would have sealed off the window
from the view of the rest of the sixth
floor we found the the boxes that he had
used for an armrest and all
top of this barricade type thing was a
paper sack with some chicken bones in it
now we found these on the sixth floor I
went down to the street to get to Crime
Lab at that point is when we met Fritz
at the front door I explained to him
what we found he went in the building I
went out to report to the senior officer
to location we stopped our investigation
when we found the spot where the shots
were fired from and later on the same
floor on the sixth floor where the rifle
was found the people talking about
getting in the building later when we
got all the physical evidence out of
there we got the fingerprints we got the
holes
we got the rifle then we had no more use
for this Google Book Depository because
we couldn't take it to court okay but
straight you say the bones that you
found on the six that's thought they
were unfair yeah that's because that's
where the fact they were on the fifth
floor also but these were not didn't
play a big part any other than that was
the first thing he saw he could take a
picture of his he said this morning okay
Tom Diller had mentioned the flatbed
truck having been removed from the front
of the motorcade at the last minute does
anyone know why the change was made also
was the parade route changed at the last
minute no we can't hear you sure try one
oh you hear me yeah I'm not positive
that we were we were actually going to
have a flatbed truck it was the custom
we expected it and we were told that we
would have one prior to the trip to Love
Field now of course I don't I don't know
who stopped it someone mentioned Lyndon
Johnson stuff that I don't know I mean I
don't know does anyone know it was what
the cameraman to writer Tom
who was you were in a convertible as I
remember were you in that convertible
with who's in there Jim Underwood which
one was he in Jim Underwood was with me
and Bob Jackson Bob I think so and then
of course a driver whoever the driver
was we don't know we were people have
told me the FBI and whatnot in the
interview said it that we were six the
car in the Freid number six is that what
you heard Bob Bob get up to the mic if
you would thanks I think we were in the
eighth car from the very lead car yeah
we might have been six back from the
president but there was a police car and
then there was oh yeah yeah no I think
we were her daughter we were six from
the president right yeah that's probably
right we could very well have been two
miles it made no difference that's right
okay Oswald's mother claims her being a
single mother and absences I didn't
realize that term was a single parent
was used thirty years ago I thought that
was fairly fairly fairly fairly new
Oswald's mother claims her being a
single mother and absence of a father
for Oswald for the way I was well turned
out what can you tell us about Oswald's
brother Robert I never knew Robert if I
saw him on the front line the other
night and he looked like pretty normal
sensible sort of guy is not much doubt
in his mind that
Jerry come tow said I'd wait McNeil come
on Earth Cochrane yeah you know that go
ahead Lee was raised by his mother I
don't think bob was he was off to
military school or a boarding school or
something like that
I had a couple of encounters with
Margaret Oswalt and if you ever had an
encounter with Margaret Oswald you might
better understand
Lee's psychology she was something else
within a couple of weeks of her son
having been accused of committing the
assassination of the president and
himself being killed we went over to do
a TV and and word interview Jack clingy
TV guy from UPI Movietone news and she's
put the hustle on us from the time we
hit the front door her first reaction
was well the the those lights or I can't
electricity I hardly paid the bill and
twenty dollar bill to help pay her
electric bill got us inside and then she
was talking about no food in the house
and the cameraman the got his car and
went down to 7-eleven and bought a sack
of groceries and that got us an
interview with with margarita Oswald
again something that I don't think is
quite normal for a mother who that just
lost the son under those circumstances
you know and then years later our a year
or so later with the release of the
Warren Commission report and it was
released to the media in Washington
about 48 hours ahead of release to the
general public and they they put a copy
of the report on the plane to me here in
Dallas and wanted a picture of some of
those participants are some of the
people involved in the thing and we
chose margarita and there was a young
reporter whose name I don't remember
with the Fort Worth Press at that time
who was kind of handling her business
for and called him and where she posed
with a with a picture of the book and he
called me back later
insist you look for $25 and $25 you know
I've still got I've still got a
photocopy of the receipt that I made her
give me received UPI $25 proposal for
the book well let's say anybody who ever
had any dealings with marguerite Oswald
with a men that she heard a little
different drummer she's a little
different drummer but her but but Bob
and all that I remember and Mike you may
know about more about this he was not
raised by my margarita he was he was
separated that's right I really never
knew Robert I met him but I've never
been doing but the Secret Service agent
Mike Howard who was the one with Charlie
Kunkel who guarded the Oswald family
after the from Sunday the Sunday right
before uncle was shot until the
following Friday they said that that
Robert Oswald was just a really a nice
guy very supportive and but totally
totally estranged from margaery he sure
came across that way as in the front
legs and they could not say enough nice
things about it but I don't really know
him I had a one here can anyone present
address the time factor involved from
when I was Walsh at JFK from the 6th
floor and when he was spotted in the
downstairs break room on the second
floor drinking a coke I didn't the
Warren Commission report I don't member
the time lag that was officer that was
Baker I think wasn't oh hey do you know
what called the fistfight between Gordon
Yoder and Jimmy Breslin enough to press
play I haven't no fight between Gordon
Yoder yeah they did I went up here on
Saturday night they said you missed show
Friday night said Yoder punch Breslin
big New York columnist at okay here's
the question will the videotape
will a videotape of the conference be
available I thought you'd never ask
if so what will be the costs you
shouldn't have asked and and who can you
order from we are taping this SMU is
taping the whole thing c-span is of
course taping it and I understand it too
I have we may get a schedule from c-span
before we leave today as to when they'll
be playing it back and do you want to
why don't you if you will Darwin yeah
explain about the videotape of course
it's being done today and we intend as
soon as possible to start editing that
into a one-hour tape perhaps an hour and
a half it seems so good and if you're
interested in that stay in touch with
the Center for Communication Arts SMU
that Center for Communication Arts
telephone number is seven six eight
three oh three oh to eight but sure
number that's my number I can't remember
the number for us
Laura lava dear Dora seven six eight
three oh nine oh I know it's also the
photographs and also are you not
planning on doing the verbatim
proceedings there has perhaps a a
verbatim proceedings we'll see how it
looks and try to put it together into a
pamphlet form
sound tape you're the second person
who's asked about that we hadn't thought
about it to start with but it looks like
there's a market out there for a sound
tape we just made and finally finally
the photograph the group photo that was
taken by various Rick's tool will be
available as well from the Center for
Communication Arts SMU seven six eight
three oh nine oh and we'll talk to
Ferris about reproducing those photos
but that can be ordered as well and I
have no idea what would be the
appropriate price okay and next question
how quickly was the Zapruder film
released to the press
does the cruder make the film available
that he present it to the government etc
but I want to say that there's a lady
here
Bobby and I sorry Bobby I don't remember
that she is back there and I was on a
talk show the other night promoting this
bit and she called in and she was a lady
out at Kodak who processed that film
that they were delighted Bobby that
you're with us today she told me that
yep I think I'm right on this story see
if I remember things correctly that the
FBI broke the film in said they wanted
run then to shut down the plant and do
it
plant manager said I can't do that Allah
called Rochester he called Rochester and
they did the they did the film they shut
it down I talked about this approver for
Hema karma came up a Dallas news and
said that he could buy it for something
like 10 or 12 grand and right but no
let's talk to people who were actually
negotiating for it and I think you were
and yeah come on Tom why don't you that
was before it was developed when Harry
came right I think Darwin paint also was
involved in in in that too go ahead I
took Harry out there that night as they
were processing the film I was trying to
get the pruder to allow me to make a
copy of one of his frames for us to run
in the mornings paper showing the the
car with the people in it at the same
time I think I I think I had as I
remember I may be wrong I think I had
permission to offer about $50 as I
remember this could be wrong to mr.
Zapruder for the permission but I know
my my pitch was that if you let me have
this
and we put it in the Dallas news this
one picture will be great publicity for
your film which should should bring you
more profit for it which seemed to be a
pretty good pitch but Harry's profit God
risked he's crazy so was to get get
control of it so he could be cut in on
the profit which Harry immediately for
so is it as a rather large amount is it
no the the bidding I think I heard the
story got up to from I think some of
some people were offering as much as
fifteen hundred seventeen hundred
dollars for that and what what was the
final price that time life paid I heard
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
is that pretty much meant okay
what doesn't someone talk about Jack
Krueger editor of the Dallas Morning
News on the grand jury and the judge
wouldn't excuse him whoever wrote that
question probably wasn't here this
morning cook we went into great detail
on that well he came in mad as hell okay
bill pay it was head of UPI his wife
Jenny was called from the bridge table
to go to Parkland she held the phone
until the Merriman until Merriman Smith
arrived well I didn't know that okay
let's see where do we go from here we
have some how did Eddie Barker get to
the TV interview with Marina Oswald
connections okay
did it have anything to do with Heineken
beer Heineken Heineken with marina
didn't you by Marina Oswald Sam Heineken
no no no is that another conspiracy
lover okay the
well this is this is the isn't this
isn't this the day to confess
okay how many okay how many witnesses
were present at the theater when Lee
Harold Lee Harvey was arrested and why
has so few of them ever been interviewed
well I think they've all been
interviewed
McDonald was interviewed Jerry this man
was everywhere he was on the magic
carpet that day get around to the mic
okay one of the main reasons that some
of the witnesses that the theater were
never interviewed were that they were
hooky shooters when we went in the front
door they went out the back the second
thing was there were seven officers
actually in on the arrest and that
included McDonald Ct Walker ray Hawkins
Tommy Hudson Bob Carol ke lines Paul
Bentley and myself in addition to that
there were several several other
officers inside the theater and outside
the theater but there were very very few
patrons in the theater at that time of
the afternoon anyway and as far as I
know at one time or another probably
every all the policemen have been talked
to and probably all of the the customers
who weren't hooky shooters had been
talked to Jerry the you're talking about
the kids upstairs in the balcony should
have been in class okay would you
comment on the relationship between
local reporters and the national
reporters I think we've become anything
on that all day as it relates to the
coverage of the events of the
assassination I think we pretty well
covered that I would like to hear more
information I would like to have more
information on the tone that was set in
Dallas prior to the president's visit
details please well again I think we've
pretty well covered that we
the I tell you story west come up you
here's the guy who he will not be
remembered for his great days as the as
the moderator on swap and shop that
great garbage sale to the air we used to
do or the fact that he was mayor of
Dallas but he will be remembered because
he took the film of that lady with that
stick hitting Adlai Stevenson over the
head and why don't you and there's also
sort of a follow-up to that that you
might want to get into well the Jim
Underwood and I were at the theater at
the Memorial Auditorium Theatre where
the UN Day was being observed and by the
way I don't know whether anybody
remembers this not Jim Jim would
remember it if he were here today but if
he were still alive but there's a riser
on that stage that that was up about
that far the riser had not been lowered
completely and after the voices of the
National indignation society and and the
other demonstrators with their banners
and so forth really got ugly
for some reason don't ask me why that
riser went boom and fell down leveled
with the thing and I thought at least
Stevenson's eyes were going to pop right
out it scared the devil out of me -
scared Jim Underwood it made - anyway he
got to be about 9:40 and Jim and I were
conversing back and forth and we said
look we can't leave now it's too
electric in here someday something could
happen by that time all of the other
television reporters had left I think
there was one still still photographer
from UPI are somewhere I think was still
there
where's Jarrett Whizzer you jerk
yeah well all the TV reporters at God
and and Jim had the weather to do at
10:15 and I had the sports to do at
10:22 and so I got the job of staying on
because I'm my sportscaster was seven
minutes later than his weathercast so I
followed Stevenson now at the door and
they were rope to the roping out behind
but behind some ropes the people there
were a valium and I'm sorry I can't
remember your name
Marie Marie she were we're standing
there and Adlai Stevenson who was then
ambassador to the UN went over to speak
to them and this lady came from behind
and and struck and rather hard over the
years you could see in those films here
and and down at the eighth floor about
the sixth floor exhibit I've always
suspected that my news director put
Walter Cronkite up to it but we he put
the film on that night on his 6 o'clock
views ran it back and ran it back twice
and said I want to thank that young
Alert cameraman in Dallas Texas West
wise for that great film just trying to
help you along yeah yeah that really
helped i got a $50 check with CBS for
that later on and this is pretty
important because the Secret Service and
the FBI was were blamed for along with
the Dallas police for the lack of
preparation I went over that badly
Stephenson film frame by frame with our
friends of the Secret Service and the
FBI and I think part of our ulterior
motive was to get on their good side but
we we looked at and examined very
closely the people in the background of
the Adlai Stevenson film for fear that
they might be present at the trademark
and as a consequence I was not only
assigned to the trademark to cover it by
Eddy but also assigned by the Secret
Service in the FBI if I saw any of these
characters that we observed in the
frames of the Adlai Stevenson film then
I was due to notify or to stop one of
The Secret Service men of the FBI so if
you hear that the FBI and the Secret
Service weren't doing a lot of work in
prep
that's not quite so because we went over
that thing three or four days as I
recall it and trying to pick out the
people that might be suspicious you know
you got it as starting again in
something that we used to back in those
days and I today we'd all be drummed out
of the Corps because we thought that the
police were pretty nice people then they
thought we were pretty nice people and
we used to do a lot of back scratching
them and it it helped us along the way
and we think that or I think that we
helped them along the way but as I say
in today's society or in today's media
that would be a no-no and we'd probably
be out there selling shoes somewhere
okay next question was was Oswald
walking toward Jack Ruby's apartment
it's always comes up at 12th 12th and
Marsalis when he shot officer Tippit in
the foreigner block of East 10th
he's right out there in that area who
wants to take that on I've been out
there and seen that and sure enough he's
kind of okay thank you were nuts
Warren Harding that is not the former
President Warren Harding but the former
state treasurer Warren Harding thank you
very much Warren I appreciate that but
no doubt about it was out there in the
same neighborhood do you think the
country's finally quote forgiven unquote
Dallas I've had a couple kick this
around a while but I've got two theories
as to what really well 3-3 is I guess
this if you Griffin e1 is one of the
things that really helped Dallas as much
as anything else where the Dallas
Cowboys
the second thing
for the TV show Dallas and I swear I
can't remember what the third thing was
what oh the cheerleaders that's right
and anybody Bobby won't add to that yeah
I wanted to say and West wise being my
year for seven years
oh yes we that's okay who put you know
there a couple of people that I did want
to get to before we get too far down the
road one was John de la Garza Johnny
here yeah okay come up to Mike as cover
story here
John was student then you can see that
he is not aged as as much as the rest of
us and oh oh that's right he was a bit
younger used a mere child and John was a
student or down at the University of
Texas in Austin and he was on The Daily
Texan down there and a bunch of those
enterprising types got on an airplane
and came up here to cover it right yeah
back back then we we thought as probably
the folks in the text and staff do now
that we were the best daily in Austin
probably still are thank you
although we published only five days a
week and I guess that's the same we
didn't publish on Saturday or Monday but
what happened was most of us heard it
one way or the other on Friday afternoon
right after lunch and most of us went
straight for the journalism building the
old Jay school which is now the
geography buildings were my son studied
less and we huddle around the AP wire
Dave McNeely was the editor
managing editor was Richard Cole who is
now the Dean of the j-school at UNC
Chapel Hill the news editor was
Charmaine Marsh who was supposed to be
here and do this today but she used to
be on Jim Wright's staff and now works
in Washington and we bunch of us huddled
I was very junior staffer then and we
decided that Dave decided we needed to
publish next or on Saturday but to do
that we needed to get people to Dallas
so three charmaine the news editor
Richard Cole managing editor and Jim
Seymour an extraordinarily talented
photographer in a very large man at the
time God in a little fairly small
single-engine aircraft I think the long
horn flying club charted from them and
came on up here three of us drove they
did their thing a lot earlier than we
did at wherever they could at Parkland
and this is the School Book Depository
we hit up here somewhere around 6:00
that evening finally in a car 5:30 or
6:00 rendezvous with them and then spent
the rest of the evening in the in the
City Hall on the third floor and an
incredible atmosphere as everybody has
talked about the streets were eerily
quiet
I remember I think was that the old
topper a little diner across the street
topper it's now a parking garage but we
ate there that and everything in them
$10 John is a parking garage thank you
thank you
but we did our thing we Jim Seymour kept
running out of film and the word spread
that there was a college team there he
never lacked for film once that was
understood everybody was our friend
everybody liked the fact that there was
a college team there and we really
didn't know what the hell we were doing
but we thought we did my goal as the
most junior member of the staff for my
job and as the Catholic in the crowd was
to find the priest who had given the the
president the last rites so I had a
payphone someplace out on the street and
just started calling and finally tracked
down the Reverend iceburg Huber who was
then he's now dead it was the president
of the pastor at Holy Trinity Church six
years later that became my parish church
and remained so so it's a kind of
strange how life how life goes on great
thank you very much John for sharing
that with us speaking of someone asked
earlier about that ad the Thank You mr.
president and John weeks who was one of
the editorial writers at the Times
Herald at the time and I were talking
earlier and he said you know it's kind
of a kind of interesting headline they
had on
add and error on that ad because they
stole it from you right John
well you heard about two statements
welcome mr. president the one back here
it was in the Star Telegram and of
course the headline of the scurrilous ad
in the Dallas news well there was a
third one on Thursday evening the day
before the president's arrival our lead
editorial and The Herald said welcome
mr. president and it was a sincere
editorial with my AC green at the time
of the assassination AC green and I were
on the editorial page staff actually we
weren't just on the editorial page to
have hell we were the editorial pants
that as has been pointed out earlier
over staffing was never a fault of the
Dallas Times Herald but at any rate this
editor I ran the evening before and
there a couple of lines at the end I
might quickly read to you the next to
the last paragraph which I now wish was
had been the last paragraph says the
eyes of the world also followed the
president of the United States at home
or abroad the eyes of the world are
following him to Dallas
we should have quit there quit while
you're ahead
right but the last line says
unfortunately we believe both the world
and John F Kennedy will like what is
seen here ooh okay John thanks for
sharing it was we're gonna wrap this up
here in a minute
go it's gonna be suppertime somewhere
before too long but here's here's a
question that that I was discussing with
someone over here during one of the
breaks and we might talk about this for
a minute if the assassination was a
state crime why was the autopsy done by
and I don't know that your wording here
is correct a non pathologist in
Washington DC or why wasn't there an
autopsy here that's a very interesting
story and there are several of you that
can can can can get into that too who
wants to take it on it was really a
a doctor dr. Rose was it who was the the
path of the county medical examiner here
vetted Charles Rose Earl Rose arrow rose
right and he tried to do an autopsy here
and the the president's entourage said
we're getting him out of here and they
moved very quickly and and did not
permit the autopsy to be performed I was
looking at the day at the arrest record
and I should have brought it I thought I
had it in my briefcase and I've lost my
briefcase so that takes care of that but
you know there's a mistake on the arrest
on the on the police report of Kennedy's
death the Dallas PD report it has his
wrong age on there do you know that type
of graphical error he was 46 when he
died and said worsen well I guess that
we ought to wrap this up you've been a
most delightful group and all of us have
enjoyed being with you and now Darwin
has a couple of closing remarks thank
you very much
well we've been waiting for the results
of that poll I've been anxiously walking
to the back of the room and we don't
have it yeah maybe you'll read about it
in the paper if we don't hear it here
but our Gary Schultz had the information
was compiling it we'll have it later
after you've gone there is much more to
say of course and but this has been a
wonderful start I think and I'm deeply
appreciative to all the journalists
who've come today things been a great
event did I hear somebody calling my
name with no we've had we have a number
of guests who are here some of whom have
been mentioned but let me mention the
some others and remind me if I miss any
officer Jim Lovell is here Oscar LaValle
is the person - homicide detective you
know who he was you might stand Jim
there he is at the back who of course
was handcuffed Oswalt at the time he was
shot Bob gemberling who was an FBI agent
who compiled the FBI report on Oswald
where are you Bob
glad to have you Tim Timmons who is
Assistant US District Attorney there's
Tim greetings Tim we've we've heard from
sergeant Jarrell Heald who was here
Bobby Hicks who processed that film
warren g harding county treasurer and
and state treasurer died miss anyone I'm
sure I've missed everyone who is here is
special and we give reeling we
introduced him yep now I've got a letter
a note from an anonymous person I'd like
to read it I think in tribute to all you
journalists who came today
you chose a career to cover the news
this fateful day in November has now
made you historians for though those of
us born in the sixties and seventies you
have made a tragic day in history become
real your presence here is rekindled
old friendships and brought back those
stories but also you have captured and
put into words the scene of the events
that surrounded those history-making
days thank you for taking the time to
pass on history I thought that was an
that coffee nice note now this has been
a very exciting weekend for us an
enjoyable one but we cannot forget that
it was a tragedy that was the genesis
for this weekend and also we remember
that many of our good friends are
journalists friends who carried this
story with us are no longer here you've
heard their names mentioned throughout
the day could we ask you to pause and
reflect for just a few moments in memory
of those journalists and also of our
president
thank you I'd like to to mention a few
other people if you'll indulge me this
whole thing began with a conversation
between Jim Yule and Alex Burton Alex
hasn't come to the microphone today a
rare occasion for Alex behead aha Alex
thank you stand up we started meeting
here at SMU to plan that event and we
composed a committee a reporter's
remember committee which consisted of
Jim and Alex myself a Hugh Ainsworth
Eddie Barker Bob Porter Gary Schultz and
Tony zoppi I think that was all the
members of the committee so we
appreciate all their work thanks also to
our videotape crew led by Lynn Smith
assisted by Wendy Adams thanks to Ralph
Miller of SMU Lynn Gartley FSM used TV
radio sequence John Gartley director of
Communication Arts thanks especially to
Susan todaro Jeff Mariah's VESA muse
catering service and a very big thanks
to the Dallas County Historical
Foundation for a wonderful party which
we had last night at the 6th floor it
was just terrific it was an out-of-body
experience to be up there on the in on
the ground floor and then moving up to
the 6th floor with all the journalists
who had worked on this story it was
really never to be forgotten event
thanks to wfaa-tv for a contribution to
this program Faris Rick's - who brought
us the all the memorabilia you see out
here in the cabinets who also took the
picture and you can order again you can
order that picture from the Center for
Communication Arts at SMU we'll give you
the details later thanks to Professor
Laura lovak and her SMU student
volunteers including the society
professional journalists here at SMU
Peggy Montgomery and Barbara Scribner as
well anything else any any other
comments closing three thoughts we oh we
got the results
partial this is this is far
regardless notes this for the audience
for the trance
well these partial only from notes that
were taken somebody better go check on
all Gary we are worried about his health
I don't know this is a partial I think
this from the audience do you believe
that Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone in
assassinating President Kennedy seventy
five guests six no and that's about you
know do you believe that Lee Harvey
Oswald was involved in a conspiracy to
assassinate the president and somehow
these figures don't match 9 yes 72 knows
something wrong there if you answered
yes to number two who was involved mafia
G at 32 mafia 14 Cuba 42 US intelligence
agents is five dollars please
so I think we can disregard those
numbers they don't seem to reflect
anything tell you the truth we get the
information off it's wise going to put
out a news release on the results of
that poll so I guess we can read about
it there that's all I have and thanks
again to all of you very much it's been
a wonderful day for us and we appreciate
your coming